[Music]
all right let's go to Sacramento and
talk to the Great and Powerful Lori
what's up
Lori hey Dr deloney thank you for taking
time to help me I don't know if I'm
gonna be any help but I will take time
to hang hang out with you what's up yeah
well I'm really excited about your new
book about anxiety um I saw your
interview with Don Madson from minimal
mom about decluttering that was awesome
and that's actually sort of where all
this started so my home's been cluttered
for years I mean boxes piled high with
my mom's clothes her dishes the kids old
toys makeup junk everything is a mess my
kids' rooms and their upstairs bathroom
were the only clean rooms in the house
so I panicked and ended up finding
minimal mom on YouTube and I felt safe
enough to start getting myself out of
this mess so after about two years I've
now got rid of about eight huge van
loads of items and with all the support
from the minimal mom Facebook group and
then seeing your interview and starting
to see some of your videos um like my
entire house is basically minimal like I
can't even believe it wow hey can I just
stop and say congratulations like like
hoarding or on the borderline of
hoarding or um as Josh Milburn with the
minimalist calls it uh hoarding organiz
organizing is just well planned hoarding
right um getting rid of that stuff is
one of the hardest things to do when
you're talking about mental and
emotional health it's hard it's hard
yeah um so congratulations that's not
not an easy task um for for some people
listening they're like oh my gosh you
cleaned your house wow no no no no this
is different this is hard so
congratulations wait to go yeah yeah
thank you yeah it wasn't cleaning my
house it was like caring ing me apart
knowing that my kids deserve a better
life and I deserve to be free of just
living in clutter and so my question is
about all the pain and conflict that
came up so like after cleaning out a
room I was supposed to be happy and
peaceful W you I was I'm like feeling
lost and angry and Confused yes and what
I think is that instead of the hoarding
disaster causing my anxiety it seems
like my anxiety was causing the Clutter
and recently I'm also thinking like
maybe childhood PTSD or something so
yeah so like how do I deal with all this
anxiety yeah you don't even need to call
me you figured it out so that stuff was
was serving as some kind of moat around
your Castle That was supposed to protect
you from the bad
guys and one those bad guys were old
memories your own nervous system your
your current relationships or lack of
your Current financial situation your
relationship with your kids whatever
that just became your thing so instead
of a drink or instead of any number of
of numbing devices you just built a wall
around yourself I would tell you there's
something tragically wrong with your
internal response system if after doing
the decluttering that you have done you
were not sitting in this home with every
anxiety alarm you have ringing off the
hook because now you're exposed now you
have to deal with whatever was setting
those alarms off in the first
place it's so um here's a weird like I
think it's the suckiest thing about
anxiety but I understand the mechanics
of
it um when you when your body identifies
a threat so let's say your daughter
comes home and slams the door and
doesn't want to talk to you and you
instantly roll back to when you were a
kid and your mom did that same thing to
you your mom would hold you hostage with
her Rel relationship if you don't make
me feel good then then I'm going to cut
you off which is like taking oxygen from
a child fast forward your daughter does
the same thing to you or your husband
does or your boyfriend does and your
body only has that one that one road
that it knows to travel and so it sets
off all the alarms and you just start
Gathering stuff around you okay yeah um
when that stuff goes away and you have
to just sit in
that now you got to deal with that
actual relationship you actually have to
grieve it now here and the crappy thing
about anxiety is when you avoid when you
get some stuff and make yourself feel a
tiny little bit better your brain goes
oh sweet that
works so the next time she slams the
door you go get more because your body
knows okay this is going to protect us
this keeps us from having to deal with
that keeps us
safe and it builds more and more and
more and so the worst part about anxiety
is you have to go through it that's the
only way that's the only way to heal
that's the only way for the alarms to
stop is to go Direct directly towards
them and that's where you found yourself
right you've cleared all the path and
now you're just staring down at that at
the other end of this thing so I'll flip
it on you you tell me when it comes to
choosing Freedom when it comes to
choosing reality when it comes to the
state of your finances you're reactive
your health what is your body trying to
get your attention and protect you
from well I I think what's happening is
that I'm
realizing the mindset that that has
started this clutter to begin with like
I've been really um feeling responsible
to take care of my mom's stuff and to
keep her
dishes and recently I had found a lot of
her old artwork she had this really
beautiful porcelain artwork and I talked
to my brother because I felt really
guilty I didn't want to sell it I wanted
to donate it and have somebody
appreciate it and I didn't want my
brother to be obs that but he was like
you know mom passed away 20 years ago
she died in
2004 and it's not I felt like I'm losing
my mind it's not like I'm
delusional but like it's been in the
back of my mind thinking about these
little pieces of objects they just
objects and it was running my life and
now I'm just feeling like
lost like now what wh when when when
when when are you gonna let your mom
go yeah and so she hold on hold on hold
on see you're you're cluttering with
words now you're cluttering with
thoughts you're going to spin it up
you're going to create a bubble around
yourself and I'm not going to let you do
it at least on this call you have to sit
in it yeah no I I'm hearing you you have
to sit in it your mom is not at rest yet
because you won't let go why
yeah um was she great to you was was it
really gnarly growing up like what was
it um she was an alcoholic and she had a
mental illness and she would go into
rages she was isolated she was paranoid
she started when I was in my teen she
started drinking really heavily but my
mom was like amazing I mean espe hold
hold hold hold such a great job it just
everything's so confusing here here's
what it is I have come to believe and
and I might sit down with a
neuroscientist someday or a child
psychiatrist they're going to tell me
I'm crazy um I don't think I am if a
parent
leaves they just disappear on you they
abandon you as a kid that is tragic on a
hundred different levels starting with
neurochemistry and then ending up in
your nervous system and all the way
through and how it manifests in the real
world I think having a parent who
struggles with addiction is worse and
here's why because they are in a child's
home they are there in body but they are
completely
gone and if a parent leaves a child has
to deal with the reality that there is
no physical presence of my of my safe
place I have to figure another safe
place
out but when they're an
alcoholic they're right
there and you ever seen those like old
spy movies where they have that three
prong hook and they tied to a rope and
they're trying to throw it over the wall
so they can catch it and they can pull
themselves up that's what kids do every
second of every day trying to connect
with Mom and Dad and if you have a mom
that you were never able to plug
into you have a little girl still asking
your herself over and over again what is
so bad about me I'll try this I'll try
this I'll try this and then she went and
died on you before you got an answer to
that and so you have not let her go oh
yeah I was in my late 30s I was in my
almost 40s when I she passed away that
does I don't care about that an adult I
know it doesn't matter that
nine-year-old girl that nine-year-old
girl is still sprinting on that
treadmill yeah and you got to sit down
with that nine-year-old you and say she
didn't drink because of
me and she loved you the best she could
but she had demons that you will never
fully realize doesn't
understand yeah that's true and you've
got to let Mom go in the
present yeah well the the first steps
that I took were trying to think about
it and the C like they had no idea what
to do don't think about it do was
declutter that was the only thing I knew
how to do and like Don and the minimal
mom Facebook group and you and I just
went to all these resources and I
thought the demons are so big I can't
think about them but I can take steps
and get one piece decluttered and that's
my home as I can start there and so in
the video game of your life you have
you've gone through all of the other
stages and you have now reached the
final
Dragon yeah right and that's why I'm
calling you because like now now what do
I do now you sit down you sit down
tonight and for the first time I want
you to write your mom a letter actually
I always tell people to write three so
you owe her
three letter number one is how much I
miss you and you have to be very
specific almost reliving in a way
remember that time we remember that time
you took me to I miss you so much and
I've had this thing that I needed you
for and you're not here and I'm so I'm
just heartbroken I miss
you the second letter has to be truth
telling
here's what you
did here's what I
missed yeah you Dr drank half of my
childhood away and the other half you
were so tired or so exhausted or so
mean and then the third letter has to be
and you can't hedge that by the way you
can't hurt her feelings she's not
here yeah but you have to let yourself
finally feel the truth that you have
never been able to tell yourself because
you hid that truth cuz you're were
trying to get her to love you somehow
and it was never about
that yeah my job was to make sure to
glue her together no my job was to be a
little kid your job was to be a
kid and the third letter is here's what
you're going to
miss here's how excited I am about what
comes next in my life and I just wanted
you to be a part of it just wanted to
let you
know did you ever have any doubt that
she loved
you well the amazing thing is when I was
cleaning up her house and I was going
through her drawers see I had gotten
into recovery and I was trying to talk
to her but she was like a really
shutdown person like you had to make
appointments to go to her house to see
her and so hold on you realize that's
Madness you realize that's
Madness yes yeah she was paranoid she
was paranoid I yeah but and I let's move
her aside I'm talking about you the
kid well the the thing that was amazing
to me that finally just it was
mind-blowing I was cleaning out her
stuff and I found a drawer full of
Alcoholics Anonymous literature she had
gone to meetings as scarce as she was of
people she was getting clean she was
getting sober it was like
Wow and that was because I took the
steps I was the first person in my
family to take the steps to go get clean
are you still
sober oh yeah well it's you know it's
really funny I didn't even do the math
since I was telling my kids yesterday
today is my 30y year clean I've been
clean and sober for 30 years today
congratulations and can I be harsh a
little bit and I mean not harsh but just
honestly you not you were clean from
alcohol drugs whatever for 30 years
which is so incredible I would hug you
if you were standing here oh yeah I I
would ask you if I could hug you and
then I would hug you the second thing is
in some ways you just traded alcohol
for
Junk yeah and so I want you to look at
this new phase as you're getting sober
again okay the 12 steps are incredibly
instructive and I know people roll their
eyes about it they're powerful because
they force you to step back and say this
is bigger than me I gotta have something
bigger than me I gotta believe in
something bigger than me I've got to
have other people I have to say these
things out
loud and you have to go make amends and
one of the the single most important
amend you need to make is to
Lori you got to let that little girl off
the hook yeah yeah is that
fair yeah absolutely well and I've
surrounded myself with the like you and
Don and the minimal Mom it's like you've
been my support group I know but I know
but we are we're imagin Facebook 12
steps we're imaginary we're not real
Dawn is no I mean I've developed
relationships with the women on the
Facebook group I know but they're not
real they're on
Facebook they're not real they are real
Don's my friend Don and I have like sat
and she's helped me personally with some
challenges Don is my friend I've got her
cell phone
number but Don and I for you are images
on a
screen those Facebook women she's been
sending me a lot of support she s she
send me videos here's what I'm pushing I
know at this point it's all I have I I
know here's your next step though you've
got to make personal relationships with
people in your world and you've got a
little girl that says I'm not worth
being loved or being around otherwise
for God's sakes my mom would have showed
up and so when you're around people your
body goes to war because people are not
safe cuz person number one that's
supposed to always be there wasn't she
was in a
bottle and so H how is
Lori going to hook be friends with Susan
who lives next door Susan's like a
banker and on the other side is Dan and
he's just weird and his cars are funny
like that's where you have to go because
your your body cannot go to rest until
it has people in the real world in real
proximity it would be failing you if if
you if it let you sleep at
night it would be failing you I've had a
oh yeah go ahead sorry no I was say it
it's job is to keep you spun up and
anxious right now because it knows we
are not safe because we cannot do Life
by ourselves and Facebook is a good Pro
a good approximation but it's not
real yeah I've had a support group of
women um since 1997 and we get together
once a month and we're each other's
lives um for what's that 25 years double
it so yeah so now I'm kind of starting
to get this whole new like the
decluttering thing and kind of starting
to reach out and kind of getting these
new groups okay so that's good yeah and
my my women's support group is amazed
and they've been holding my hand with me
like every step of the way and now I'm
kind of getting these new Facebook
friends and the thing I love about them
is they know what I'm talking about my
women friends love me but they're like
wow we don't know and the women on the
group and like I'm starting to get
people who understand this whole um
piece of my life that's just opened up
in this last two years so now I'm
starting to get
those branch out here's next step I want
you to write those three letters and
it's going to take a couple of days I
want you to spend letter one spend a day
or two letter two spend a day or two
letter three it's spend a day or two and
then I want you to call the women the
real life
women into your home your new clean
decluttered home and they'll all be
amazed give them a tour let that sink in
how proud of of of you they're going to
be I want you to feel that don't deflect
it oh no it's because of dawn it's
because of delone no no no no we're just
people on podc you did the
work and then I want you to read the
letters to them out loud in person s let
them sit in a circle around you I want
you to feel that
room let your body feel that room let
your body feel we are not alone as David
Kessler says grief Demands a witness
we're going to grieve in front of our
friends at some point not before but
maybe after you post those letters to
your Facebook
community and they are going to be your
community that walks alongside you that
says okay now that we're here you got to
go see a trauma counselor you got to
deal with that you've got to start going
to allenon meetings you've got to sit
down and do some body work or some EMDR
or you got to do some heavy duty stuff
to let your body be at peace with
letting your mom
go and the things that you've had to
make peace with relationally with your
kids or your friends that you've heard
over the years you're going to have to
make peace with that but that is not
done by yourself just thinking about it
can't cannot be done thinking about
it it's got to be done in reality with
your body I'm really I mean to tell you
I'm proud of you is like the
understatement of the year I I don't
have the words for it you inspire me I
got a lot of decluttering I got to do
with my my house in fact Don and I have
talked extensively about it um and by
the way for everyone who's listening if
you struggle with that stuff Don Madson
is amazing um you can check out her
stuff um Josh Fields Milburn and TK
Coleman and Ryan Nicodemus with the
minimalist they're incredible too
they're also great friends really great
folks in in Walking you through the
decluttering process they've got some
some plans on how to do it at my house
is just so overwhelming um they're
really
remarkable hang on the line Lori I'm
going to send a copy of my brand new
book on me I'm just for free and uh uh
Jenna will get it sent to you I'm proud
of you I'm proud of you do those three
things tell your friends and then holler
back girl at me and you're supposed to
say I ain't no holler back girl holler
back and then I want to see how I want
to let everybody know who listens to the
show how you're doing I'm proud of you
it's
awesome